- You got a little scared.
- Look at this.
It twirls nicely with a little bit of coffee on it.
- They got that pumpkin spice.
- This is life and death right here for me.
- Welcome to the punishment
edition of the B/R
Gridiron Punishment League.
Lou and Amanda were teamed up this week
against FlemLo and I.
The new underdogs, being us, came back
and took care of business over
Scottie Pippen and MJ.
I got freaked out late Sunday afternoon.
- Jack texted mid-game, "Oh s—-t!"
- Did you guys think the comeback was on?
- I had hope.
- It was Stafford and Murray.
We needed some big points
there late in the fourth, and you got lucky.
- Thank God.
- We were supposed to dress up
as fairies. I am a beer fairy.
- And I am Father Fairy
Shlou, just here giving blessings.
- I like how they both put like their unique
little spin on the costume idea.
They put some thought in it.
- The punishment of this week
is to eat the guts of a pumpkin, and I
am prepared.
- Let's get this pumpkin eating going.
- Look at this
- Ooh, the guts.
- I got a little hot sauce.
- Oh, hot sauce.
- I got a little salt. I got a little pepper.
- Lou came prepared. Lou's making lunch.
- Salt and pepper.
- I don't eat nothing without no seasoning.
- Should I pour a little coffee in here?
- Yeah.
- Cheers.
- It's just like oodles of noodles.
- Here we go.
- Ugh. Uh uh.
- What's the best part, the seeds or the guts?
- None of it.
- Is it sweet?
- No, this s--t ain't sweet.
- Mine is! I put a little coffee in there.
Trying to even drink mine like a coffee.
- I'm telling you, the hot sauce make it OK.
- We dodged the perfect bullet
because this would have been
the one took me out right here.
- I'm telling you, sometimes you just gotta get a little dirty.
You gotta put the forks and the knives away, the utensils.
You gotta just put your foot in it.
It's like my nanna used to say.
- Lot a seeds for you, Lou.
- Ain't go down easy, though. Come on, bro.
I want my revenge.
- You were saying 'run it back.'
- They're not eating this pumpkin.
They're going to underprepare next week.
- Let's run it back, bruh.
Let's see what happens.
- I think after this,
I might rather drink an egg.
- How many calories we think we're eating right now?
- Hey Jack, don't say we.
[laughter]
- I'm gonna save this pumpkin,
and I'm going to carve it.
- Yeah, carve a big, big fat
L for Lou and losers.
All right. Get your final bites in.
We're tapping you guys out.
- This is all the pumpkin
I need until next year.
- Kill or be killed right here.
- We shall see you in Week No. 8.